i went looked at dictionaries and i did
want to say that i also looked at this a
dictionary of ecology evolution and
systematics which is a book i used to
assign to my upper division science
students
i think that the second edition which is
what this is which was published the
second edition was published in 1998
reprinted in 2003 that's the version i
have here
at least while i was still teaching
they had stopped at the second edition
and it wasn't being republished much
but i went and i decided to look up the
relevant terms here and of course woman
isn't in here because this is a
dictionary of ecology evolution of
systematic systematics basically being
mac revolution the the deep history
um
and it's it's a fabulous resource it
really is uh female though i looked up
female
and uh
to my surprise not at all found
the egg producing form of a bisexual or
dioecious organism
compared to male
okay
so that's all exactly as we have already
described um but i thought
oh right dioecious uh well diocese
warrants
a uh
a definition and while i
assumed that both of us could provide
one off the top top of our heads
i looked it up in here as well
and it says used of plants or plant
species having male and female
reproductive organs on different
individuals unisexual
um dioecious
um
compared to
monitious or triesis
and
try it right and so that's where i went
oh what well i looked up trieshus and um
let's see did i did i tag it i did try
issues so let's just say that di daisy
dioecious is
is what we call hermaphroditism
in um no no diocese is uh monicius is
what we call hermaphroditism in animals
so we just because botanists and
zoologists i don't know don't get along
or just you know generated words
separately um we have we very often have
different words for the same things um
so what you would call a hermaphroditic
species in an animal you would call a
monicious species
which means one house one house exactly
and so with regard to triacious i went
what
what are they talking about used of a
plant and this actually this this
connects perfectly to what you said
about um sophistry and making an
exception for intersex
use of a plant species having male
female and hermaphrodite flowers on
different individuals
so this is a case in which there are
three types of individuals and we know
of no cases i know of no cases in which
animal species do this yep but a species
in which there are male individuals
there are female individuals and there
are simultaneously hermaphroditic
individuals tries three houses again um
and so i actually want to just do a
little diversion into isis and oikos and
everything
but
no there's not some third category the
third category here the third type of
individual is
you know you have a you have b or you
have a and b
it's not c it's not a third thing it's
not an 87th gender right like it's it's
it's a and b it's not it's not a totally
new thing um so that sent me just
because i went here and i thought it was
kind of fun
um
into so ishas
which is the same route as the echo
actually in ecology and economics comes
from the greek for oikos the greek
meaning household which is oikos and
indeed there's an ecological journal
called oikos
and it has a lot of different meanings
actually in greek and it turns out to be
a very important word
but in looking up what
what it really means i found this paper
leshem 2016 published in 2016 in the
journal of economic perspectives
the paper is called retrospectives what
do the ancient greeks mean by okinomia
which i guess is the root for um
economics
and i just wanted
to share one sentence from this this is
the journal of economic perspectives
published in 2016.
um
deep in the article he says
the earliest appearance for the root
word for okonomiya is found in a poem by
facilities in the 6th century before the
common era that reflects the misogynic
he says mesogenic spirit of texts from
this age the poet classifies women by
comparing them to different kinds of
animals and advises friends advises his
friends to marry a bee-like wife because
she is quote a good economist who knows
how to work but can almost usually
translate as stuart
so that was um entertaining for me to
discover
and it
it reflects
part of why i think some smart people
are legitimately confused right that
there is of course a long history of
sexism and misogyny in all of the
important intellectual traditions 100 we
know this anyone who claims not is is
lying to themselves or to you right and
so we see that here that doesn't mean
just as you have already said that there
is some you know
patriarchy that is
stealing food from women or you know you
know whatever whatever it is that they
are that they are claiming
but that there are patriarchal
structures in place
that have in part um sort of handed the
domain of the domestic to the females
and handed the public-facing outward
domain to men and that of course leaves
men with power and resources
to control is is of course true um but
that doesn't change the underlying truth
of what male and female are and
um
so let me just uh
yeah follow on from there yes
this is one of the reasons people uh who
watch this channel or listen to it
regularly will have heard me invoke
lineage a million times
this is one of the reasons that it is so
essential that we begin to think
evolutionarily in terms of lineage right
because as long as the problem is that
the individual is more tractable right
it is easier to comprehend right what is
the lineage right well a lineage is
actually a fractal right you're a part
of many lineages simultaneously so it's
a little bit hard to wrap your mind
around it and what level is operative in
any given interaction
but until you do
you can start thinking that there is a
patriarchy and that that patriarchy is
inflicting things on
women right and the point is
no that wouldn't really make any sense
in a lineage context right the lineage
may
divide things very unfairly in fact
pregnancy itself
is very unfair right tell me about it
yeah right well this is a perfect
opportunity for me to mansplain stuff
yeah right tell me about how rotten
pregnancy can be well but that's just
the thing is it's for you because you
had to live with me oh my god no this is
exactly this is exactly it is the fact
is it is unfairly divided but it is
unfairly divided by biology not by
uh men being insensitive to women right
it's non
equally divided
let's just
you know
there are lots of i mean look warfare
that's dudes that's also unfairly
divided it's unfairly divided
but the point is these things have been
divided up
because it got our lineage into the
future right now as you and i make the
point in our book
we are up
for a renegotiation of a lot of these
things right you can't renegotiate
pregnancy we probably should not
renegotiate war for the most part but
maybe think about how
you know that's a short-term
strategy that's going to make it
impossible to live on this planet but
nonetheless the point is
we are here we can work together to
reduce war right
but you know the actual war part biology
and getting getting into the future is
not easy we got here we got here with a
lot of stuff unevenly divided in lots of
different ways right and more evenly
dividing that which can be more evenly
dividing divided is a good idea
but pretending that this is about
somebody being mean
right is preposterous that's just not
how lineage works and
um anyway you know look
at some play you know we've seen the
sophists now argue that the reason that
women's sports were invented was not to
protect women from male competition but
exactly the reverse right
how far can we really be from an
argument that women's prisons were
invented to protect male prisoners from
being assaulted by women who had
committed crimes yeah
right female criminals can be rough
they can and so you know yes men
invented these uh women's prisons to
protect uh male prisoners right
that argument's coming at some point
presumably and we have an obligation to
learn how to stop being so damn
responsive as if the fact that an
argument is difficult to field means
that it's valid right a lot of these
arguments just aren't valid and are
obviously not valid even if you can't
put your finger uh on the reason why in
the moment
and i guess they'll ask and that doesn't
make you wrong right so i would i would
point out that there's a trick that uh
people will use an argument sometimes
which is if you say something
they will ask you to define a word
in what you've said
right
you will find that if you give yourself
the assignment of defining the important
words and the arguments you make it's
very difficult right we constantly use
words that we cannot define and that is
not an indication that we are fakers it
is an indication of the way the meaning
of words is held it's not held in the
conscious mind in a place that you can
immediately bring up the you know the
the meaning of any of the things that
you're saying and so
um you know the sophists can use this
against you until you realize that your
inability to define a word is not an
indication that you don't know what it
means right um and i guess you
know let's stop being backed into a
corner by this stuff
excellent
[Music]